what does this year's crop of the best
of the best tell us how do they stand up
to the truth test do they even want to
it's not escaped everyone's attention
that one of our number is accused in
some quarters of being a hoax
so tonight as we celebrate and talk
about the work maybe we'll get some real
insights into the state
of our beloved art
what happened was that
banksy came to us with the idea
and then he kind of left us alone for a
while
because we had a lot of uh work to do
with the rushes and um he kind of gave
us
he gave us a lot of room with that to
find the story
and really banksy wasn't
uh particularly interested in being in
the film himself he didn't start off
with that idea that was more um
something that came from from us from me
and the editor
that we thought that we needed um
we needed his take on on this story it
actually started off being um
his attempt to tell the story of street
art through
this guy terry's rushes um to have been
filming for a long time
yeah in fact i mean banksy came up with
the idea of taking over the film and
then
sometime later he approached me to
i mean what do you think when people do
say this whole thing is a kind of joke
well
it completely baffles me because it
isn't it isn't a joke it's uh i mean in
in the kind of uh almost boring way is
the complete opposite it's it's a very
uh
conventionally told true story of
something that happened between two
people we have the two people telling
it's a double header you know they tell
their side of the story i mean we're
very fortunate that we have um some
fantastic rushes we have a great wealth
of archive material which of course is
key to the story
the story was happening in the real
world terry went off and i mean when we
heard that madonna had commissioned
terry to do her album cover we all i
mean we literally all fell off our
chairs we couldn't believe it we simply
completely and of course now people
think the power of banksy is so great
that he somehow influenced madonna to
make terry you know all of these things
that were happening in the real world
were a revelation to us and and nothing
that we'd ever expected was he pleased
with the film
banksy yeah yeah i think he's very
pleased with that but he won't be
showing up
not as well as i know okay
it's a detective story um it's it's very
hard to find out the real information
about this i had to go and get it had to
wan i wanted to experience what was
happening whether or not that was going
to be a film or something i was just
going to report back to
people in my area
so i think we just we followed the
geography matt sanchez the co-creator
and editor and i just basically
had to go through a process of
remembering every step of the way
and that became the narration that
became the discovery process and also
needed to be funny because the people i
mean we took our sense of humor from the
folks in the film obviously you have
this incredible gallows sense of humor
that comes through i met josh when he
did the first segment over two years ago
and he wasn't quite sure if it was going
to become a full-length feature at that
time
and i was pretty active in the community
because when i heard about this i was
stunned at the thought of it in our
backyards in such a pristine clean
environment in upstate new york and um
when he showed me a rough assembly i
immediately became fully committed on
every level it's hard to separate
filming from editing from talking about
this it seems to happen every single day
we're outside when did you know when to
stop
sundance deadline sunday sundance i mean
right
george w bush you know really got me
started in film you know first the iraq
war and then the financial crisis it's
kind of hard to beat that guy
although
unfortunately i have to say barack obama
in this area the economic realm is
giving mr bush a run for his money very
sadly the film is unfortunately uh
about the ways in which
an increasingly
uh criminal and
remarkably powerful industry has
hijacked uh not only the machinery of
finance but but the united states
government and
its ability to make policy and also as
as we were discussing earlier
the
the academic institutions and and people
who
should be able to
criticize these things and speak openly
about them
so many people have seen especially
glenn hubbard and frederick mishkin and
said why on earth would they agree to be
interviewed and i think i mean they said
yes so easily and i think it's because
they had never been challenged on this
subject before
and we had
interviewed glenn hubbard first he's the
head of columbia business school and two
weeks later we wanted to interview
mishkin who also was at columbia
business school same building
so we really didn't think we were going
to get away with it
because if you if you've seen the
interview with hubbard he's clearly very
unhappy with us so we
we showed up with a very small crew that
day i kind of tried to dress like a
student a little bit
charles wore a baseball hat which he
never wears
and
we got away with michigan's interview as
well
you know we've been at war for 10 years
um that's a very political
fact it gets argued about and should be
argued about
um
but there's a whole generation of young
men and women who have been sent off
volunteered and been sent off to fight
these wars
and they have
maybe the most profound and probably
disturbing experience of their lives
over there
and then they come back and we have no
idea what it was like for them
we have an intellectual a political
understanding of what war is
um but we don't know what it feels like
for them we don't know what it feels
like to be in combat and we wanted to
make a film
that puts you there with them a neutral
film
that the far left the far right pro-war
anti-war that everyone
can experience and engage in and so when
these people come back
the better we understand their what they
went through
the more easily the more successfully we
can give them
their rightful place back home
you know i watched recently on through
twitter
the uh the proliferation of the film and
the one thing i've noticed is twitter
combined with netflix
has meant that although we had a
theatrical across the country over the
summer played in over 300 theaters
the film is really gaining ground
recently because there are a lot of
people in this huge country that don't
necessarily live near cinemas that will
just put out these kind of films and yet
they want to see this information and uh
i think already social media is having a
huge impact on our our industry and our
business and you know i think that's a
good thing and at the same time we need
to get out there and document and that
you know i think that these
people do want to see real life because
they understand that real life has a
bigger hold over them than than anything
that hollywood can make up there's a big
thing about everything with our film was
very much about getting the story out
and just arriving on this remarkable
story of remarkable characters and in
terms of and i always find it quite
amusing today when people say oh it's a
great environmental film because we
didn't set out to make an environmental
film that other people say it's a great
social film
we've got bolsheviks who love it because
the workers are getting together and
we've got capitalists who love it
because these guys are creating a little
new company and we've got religious
people who love it because about the
spirit of god and all this other stuff
but i think when we were there it was
very much just about the story was
really good and the people were just
amazing ten years ago i
learned about catadoras and garbage
people who pick through garbage for
recyclables and um
had studied
that a little bit in this class i just
kind of sat in on for a laugh in
10 years ago i knew that that project
would be
all the rich food for thought that i
think wasteland generates